won't get in till tomorrow you will shut
your face and I'll kill you stab you in
the butt
and then ream you through a rake of
glass uh-oh is he able to think that you
might have been the butt stabber what
kind of crazy accent was that way it's
just one that I've never used before
that I happened to come up with that guy
from uh Andy Griffith Show the stupid
barbecue sheriff guy that I would shoot
some sarni what yeah
Oh Doug dimmadome from dimmsdale
dimmadome no there's too many ostriches
lever selenium Oh Andy I didn't know the
Rinda extreme sex or something there was
that parody of it I can't remember what
room
maybe those thumb Mel cells well I don't
pee on porno I like at your bar D sounds
just like your shaggy all right everyone
energetic raise you be entertaining yeah
yeah Bobby for this okay it's me and
Wade ah come on
she's gotta be me anyway you [ __ ]
okay wait just let me do my thing and
you go don't get in my way
my jobs to suit the other person got it
dear Jesus all the way I was just baby
out of our way apparently have a really
good spot so we'll just ran right past
me oh really
excellent me man who have a package made
it a real bad job I mean who put summer
sellotape on a box a [ __ ] what is
sellotape it's you know sticky stuff you
know it's sort for cellophane taste I'd
say it was a poorly wrap on them I don't
think that has anything to do with his
way you do a sausage ha ha what ha ha I
I'm vegetarian no you are you man I'm
Jay again okay your applique rightly
offended I'm just vegetarian for
sausages mmm what wait what
you're only vegetarian sausages that
what you're saying yeah they're the best
I don't ever kill the hell weren't you
did yeah Oh
Jesus how much hell did you have I shot
you up at Julian time what a giant just
something you just missed a bajillion
times maybe you should shut up okay we
ride it Bob right now yeah that's a good
spine right it's not bad
wait wait I don't even see where you are
where's Bob I'm taking oh wait are you
oh I did it it kill me
wait all those things I said about you
and your mother and all those horrible
things I told you about
oh you want to give me a hint good buddy
wait tell me hit me no oh here right yes
what are you walking about you so many
time but right over there a bunch I
can't believe I guess I spawned in the
game spectating him ah it was dark I
couldn't see it's not my fault you're an
idiot you you're yeah I'm who's an idiot
no no I am who's on first
I'm an idiot you're on first good hiding
spots cuz I've got my senses and they're
all tingling right now what's tingling
my something tingling yeah I think they
make an ointment for that yeah it's
pretty bad actually I need to get it
checked out tell me about down
subscribing how's it pulsing is losing
anything it's kind of a bit green and
there's some wait a second is that you I
felt like like my shaloo got green and
yellow and I I know what I think someone
tried really hard to put that milk back
in the right place and didn't know
already being cut oh I sounds like Matt
got away yeah well Wade you sure suck
the back teeth on that one but my teeth
yeah you're gonna get potato bald no I'm
not what is it potato ball it's a balls
you'll see you and I you get you know
we'll just have to find out or whatever
yeah they lie in the next episode
yeah uh-huh family okay
did I spec take more spec take what the
heck is spec take I'm confused did you
see mark or not no by l'a he's just tie
yes us know over to your left no behind
you in front of you underneath you
hahaha I'm right on top of you
he's everywhere I know where you ball
for the confused looking everywhere I'm
so confused right now potato balls you
look like a giant [ __ ] you know where
you are 100 maybe trying to murder us
viciously blowing out very offensive to
my potato balls oh how can you not find
me I'm behind Mars okay I know where you
are now after sir he's gonna be here
really oh really oh so well done
Yuval shall be keep shooting yes not
quite no even see us yes I saw both of
you okay I don't you know I see one of
you now I see kind of oh it was a little
bug right here in the corner we could
say hey bob was in the dark so it was
really ha
I was huge though oh okay oh oh oh it's
so dark I want the guilt of sight back
oh we're gonna oh I have an idea we're
gonna have a little competition this
this playthrough whoever can make the
weirdest face throughout the entire
playthrough wins an award what is the
award cuz it really depends how good is
another gift of my love I don't really
love that ah
nice toss someone moving Wow where you
going where you going where'd you go
where'd you say I'd to go where'd you
yeah you lost me I get off my face hurts
already
good it's not holding the face oh wait
he's around here
where you lost me there's a milk jug
he's all shook all right well I'm gonna
start putting faces on cuz I want to get
this gift yeah you want to get a gift
let's make a gift of all of us just
making the weirdest face Basel ready go
I expect like 10 bajillion gifts of that
made on tumblr tonight tonight you're
demanding something that this is gonna
be out tonight
ha ha ha later on tonight them is not
tonight to us because it's not or not
yeah exactly see I'm speaking to them
from the future but how fast when
they're Ian's they act fast I love that
yeah yeah me are you still alive
yeah I'm still I'm still chillin I'm I'm
just like jogging out is that a word
rocking out you I'm uh I'm uh hi where'd
you go teen or something I don't know
what I'm for Oh got ya cool as long
somebody kills me it took you two years
you don't found me straightaway
yeah whatever you went around a corner
and I couldn't find you anymore okay
wait I mean right now he's got to be
somewhere
mmm far away ha but Wow where is he yes
he was sweet
oh I thought I shot those said he was
joking out so he was a steroid team joke
yeah she's flirty you know I've been
taking some of those yeah is he doing
you good I got muscles on muscles now
Blake doesn't blame yourself
well oh shut up Jess I'm so well it's
amazing she screams animal zoo in there
is Reston
we did yeah you better go say it
hey will you stop doing that and a
really unhappy but not too mad voice you
know this is what I'll be able to give
her a very cross expression to know yes
you please wash your arm that and say
look look I think you're wonderful
person but that was not nice I like
country yeah clue please yo chill me
that's not fair
I couldn't get the box to break your bed
I know I so I know he heard one of me I
know you heard oh hey okay alright where
are you so my seats I haven't seen ya
like how we matched I see you both we
didn't even plan this bus but it's kind
of a cheap clue do you bleach that cuz
it's already nice white get tough it's
tough to me good no oh yeah I have the
same problem I'm gonna show you wait
till your boy laid the way does that
obey the in plain sight rule
I'm sure doesn't oh where is he
he was impossible to see oh wow that was
a good move though that was very nice
and he's on the run
potato balls can't see em ice cream
doesn't have any idea what the hell's
going on anymore
I'm always giving him the ring around
he's moving through the tunnels like a
maniac on wheels except he's off Otto
you need the shoutcasting a bottle of
pure adrenaline coming at you straight
from the depths of hell
now for six easy payments of $29.99
loves highway throw in a free bottle of
Cola whoo you know I'm following you
right oh it's gonna corner him and kill
him hilariously know what I was just an
even see it coming you know I just
threat you then one of my potato bowls
oh they scrape on impact
taking you guys well buttered in
garlicky oh yeah sure I'd have had
spices to spice it up your life it's too
bad cuz your potato balls and I could
sure make a heck of a couple huh one day
if you buy a dozen potato balls today
we'll throw in a free potato masher
signed by yamimash
whoo oh I see I'll even I'll even kiss
you
it's a Toastmaster minidom yom is that
the slogan is again yeah that's pretty
bad slogan I got it was the greatest
again when you feeling full get some
potato balls they are good for all of
you yeah I think somebody yes they're
just a powdery stuff Oh potatoes
potatoes we love to eat them so potatoes
potatoes I'm gonna kill you did remember
our little song Wade you remember huh
remember our song for the commercial we
were gonna make know why we just
recorded it like two days ago you didn't
wonder hey hey are you sure that's
copyrighted by now what you dig you dog
I think it'll be really funny if we get
a copyright ID for like from some potato
industry for using that song and they
said that they claim it's theirs
like imagine if you randomly sing a song
it was actually a real song from
something well not to spoil it we were
gonna make commercials and the logo for
the commercial was gonna be it's Martina
but I was sure with you the hell is
going on here
Bob sums up the [ __ ] is up I know I see
you what are you shooting at I've got
your reticle I became the indestructible
table Wow oh no no you guys only a kill
me he ami mad just so you know you're at
about a 90 degree angle to where you
want to be Oh
oh you weren't even close to being
correct how is that very I looked
perfectly stable and aligned you looked
exactly like a bench in the middle of
the hallway yeah and that's what he
killed me is that what you were going
for what I was trying uh well to be fast
somebody did run past me twice and
started spinning bowls around so I did
quite good that's a good choice mark
thank you I tried real hard huh okay oh
I'm going to die no what did I miss
wait wait ghosts in this room
Molk scissor box that's right no no no
no no don't speak no no no no no hello
ah you can open that no fair no way I
know you can open that oh oh oh oh now
cuz I keep moving up my words I didn't
think you guys would look in there right
away
okay you guys suck ass
lots of it hey Han Betty honey open the
door I'm sorry alright could be a ghost
and troll for a while the first thing we
always do is check the room were in duh
but I will now alright I think I'm in a
good spot I won't die within the first
20 seconds no siree oh I almost
definitely not die within the first 20
stylin I'm waiting for it I've got the
countdown going uh-huh
yeah whatever furnace happen 'el
countdown shut up wait it's the final
countdown it's the initial countdown
it's the conclusory countdown it's the
time at the end where we sing the
numbers down some
10 9 8 7 6 - 31 huh ha ha I gotta get to
the stupid bench to see if it was really
you or not
wait wait what was he house bonus a like
a little cardboard box over here was do
you know I was I'm dead he didn't even
recycle me that bastard that bastard
god dammit yes I am gonna come in there
eat you Bob what are you see him there
his jugs just got banged by my leave I
thought he was a jug someone put down
the box incorrectly over there what an
egg pair Jill Jeff yeah good I'd like
the milk
oh that's good like Jerry gonna generate
an awkward silence that probably would
generate an awkward silence in almost
every situation I like to milk them I'd
love to milk them I might try that the
bar next time see really to see if you
could pick up chicks
I know so milkman and that'll be my
rebel one of them is a medium-sized
wooden crate no no no no way Guyer ha ha
ha way that is the most conspicuous
thing I've ever seen in my entire life I
just saw one move I'm Rob I could the
other one is a milk drug cuz they hid it
in a horrible hiding spot Oh what are
you talking about I am too softly
talking about God I'm just looking for a
medium-sized box right now no no what
are you talking about oh really not that
yes nice book I came right out in the
open which is too good that was yeah
whatever pretty good job there Marc but
I if I hadn't found that other milk jug
yeah I know yeah I know I know and
kicked out of this game
guys look